long way since launch and today earth's
mightiest heroes are launching on
playstation 5
xbox series x and s and the team's
roster is growing
avengers you finally arrived
bruce there's only the maestro now
breathe in the desolation that surrounds
you
barton i will save you from it all
[Music]
check out this extended gameplay from
operation hawkeye future imperfect
hey hot guy long time
good to see you how's my dog doing
lucky's great i love that dog
but wait didn't you move out today what
no what makes you say that they said
they were movers
[Music]
francis barton what great timing
do i know you watch dogs ames hired guns
surrender quietly or die noisily
you thinking what i'm thinking this goon
squad is going down
[Music]
oh that won't feel good in the morning
we've established a direct connection to
the future time bridge
i've made the necessary modifications so
uh
what's your plan i left fury in the
future when i jump back from the time
bridge
if he's alive i'm getting him out then
we can use this project omega intel to
stop the end of the world
fair enough let's find him
got eyes on the mercenaries knocking
loose kate knocking loose
don't let us
i require assistance
how can people live in a world like this
a memorial whatever i thought they might
have been through
it's worse all these missing
people think they're still out there
i don't know
did you think the supreme leader hadn't
noticed you you shouldn't be here
and soon you won't be taskmaster
oh look he's an ugly washed up shield
agent in the future too
nice to know some things never change
[Music]
you're making this far too easy yeah
sure don't you survive
you're always looking out for yourself
and now let's take a glimpse into some
upcoming content
[Music]
[Music]
you